hey guys so today I'm gonna be unboxing
some new cases that my friends at Nomad
just recently released this is really
special because these are cases that
work with moment lenses this is a moment
case that I've had on my phone ever
since I've been getting really into
these lenses I am such a huge fan of the
moment I love their brand I love their
photography the Maples of their
Instagram everything about them is
awesome and everything about Nomad is
also incredible they have a lot of
really great products much like this
this is a little air pods case you guys
know I did a massive air Paul's case
haul with some really hideous cases this
is not hideous
this is high-quality and awesome so
Nomad did a collab with moment to make
cases that will house the lenses we're
gonna check those outs and also some of
my little moment gear that I had
purchased not too long ago I was working
on my session for vlog university
talking about different mobile options
and this is really one of the highlights
because you're able to take these really
high quality lenses attach them to your
iPhone case and just increase the
quality of shots that you can get on
your phone just as a little refresher
here's the moment case it's it's fitting
through some things they also have these
little straps that you can get there's
little holes right here so this has been
really cool to be able to just hold on
to my phone and this actually isn't a
Nomad strap this is it's from an old
Canon little Power Shot camera but if I
can hold a small little camera then yeah
you can hold my phone let's check out
the cases I'm probably gonna go with
this black case the brown one looks
really good too and these are all
leather and I figure out how to open it
everything is great
I am box things for a living
tada there it is
all of our stuff is really high-quality
it's really soft it's uniquely rugged
day one a 100 and if you've ever had any
type of leather products you obviously
know that it does wear differently and
I'm pretty abusive with everything that
I have so my day 100 will probably be
here a lot quicker like day 20 oh that's
nice look at that look how gross my
camera lense is you're disgusting yes
what moment has the lens cleaner and
then over here on the other side it's so
cute I can clean your lenses mints is
mostly made to clean their lenses but
guess what it also cleans your iPhone
lens it's cool because this case is
designed to have the lenses just screwed
right into it so that's why you have to
have a specific case to use the lenses
so that's the black version let's check
out the brown oh this looks good too
Oh child aside now what do you think
this looks this definitely looks like
more year vibe I like it yeah this looks
good okay I'm gonna put this on just
because we need to see what it looks
like you know what else is great they
also replicated the bottom design so you
can use those same sort of straps on
here which is amazing whoa I feel I feel
kind of like sophisticated hi I just
seen here welcome to my office
okay do I need to get into like this
brown mother like that looks so freakin
good
can I get closer yes I can
whoa mm-hmm
yeah and that's not all
we also have an air pods pro case to
match oh my goodness I also have this
for my old version of my ear pods looks
really good let's put this on you'll see
there's like a little dot right there so
you'll be able to see the charging light
that's that's beautiful
honestly nothing says you're a CEO like
this hello ah yes yes this is the CEO of
iJustine incorporated speaking oh you
want to talk to the president oh you're
also talking to the president yes
uh yes I will close on the deal I'm
gonna have to take this call and
transfer to my air pods
please hold being a CEO is really CEO
lifestyle
I can't hear anything Nomad makes really
awesome stuff I also have a really cool
Nomad keychain that Nomad once sent to
my sister but I thought it was for me
and I opened it and then I kept it and
then they asked if she ever got the
package and she said no a lot of times
things are shipped to me and Jenna but
they will just put a J guess what we
both have the same initial so J is Eric
we are both JD's Eric I think that this
is the case that I'm gonna use for now
because I want it to match my earpods
case but I also my gosh what am I gonna
do either way these both look awesome so
I think that I'm ready to carry on well
test out some of the lenses for
something to give this a nice little
clean so clean these just screw right on
to the top lens now there are other
cases obviously for other phones this is
look how good this looks
so this is the telephoto lens they have
a bunch of different ones
I even love this little case I can carry
all of my little lenses with me this is
a little travel one if you just want to
carry two lenses which is probably
realistic there's an anamorphic one
which I showed in one of my other videos
that I made and this is still probably
one of my favorite it's the wide angle I
would school about this is new I think
well there is already a wide angle on
the iPhone but this will get you wide
angle night photos alright there we go
so that's just a really quick look at
some of the lenses now I'm gonna take
these outside and get some cool shots
and of course some b-roll of my new
classy lifestyle
[Music]
testing out the moment lens this is the
wide-angle lens it's pretty cool the Sun
has just set so we're slowly losing
light this is like the perfect time to
take photos and video because the light
looks awesome look at these little ducks
hi little ducks hey hey you guys
[Music]
well that was just a quick little look
at some of these Nomad cases that now
we'll work with moment lenses I like
this because it's a little bit different
than the standard moment cases that they
have on their website
so now you have another option when
trying to find cases to use with your
mamma lenses make sure you guys
subscribe and hit the bell so you guys
will be notified when I post new videos
and if you guys enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and if
there's anything else that you would
like to see me make videos about leave
it in the comments below and let me know
what you guys think of these cases and
which one do you think that I should
ultimately go with the brown or the
black I don't know what to do
[Music]
and everything is awesome